no one has come forward to claim
responsibility for the op-ed but the
writers claims have already caused
disruptions within the administration
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning the vice
president's do-over speaks to the deep
level of distraction for his staff for
the White House and it continues even
though the vice president told CBS News
that that op-ed and Bob Woodward's book
mischaracterized the way this White
House works we have done our own
extensive reporting on this and we've
talked to former and current officials
who say part of working here is to
achieve things for the president but
also to derail bad ideas sometimes
viewing that process the dérailleur bad
ideas as is important as pushing the
good ones forward and as this
controversy over the op-ed continues the
level of distraction for the White House
and the vice president's office
intensifies and amid all this Nora the
president's suggesting and the vice
president affirming the possibility of
widespread lie detector tests in the
White House to find the op-ed writers
identity talk about a level of
distraction I cannot imagine that lie
detector test major thank you